[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: I am really, really
excited to bring onstage
Rochelle Briscoe, who is
an HR people partner here,
at YouTube.
We've got Taraji coming on
stage, who I don't think
needs an introduction.
We've got Robin Bissell,
who was the writer
and director of this
very amazing movie,
"The Best of Enemies."
And then we've also got
Dominique Telson coming on,
who produced this movie.
Please welcome them.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
DOMINIQUE TELSON: [INAUDIBLE].
ROCHELLE BRISCOE:
Well, as you can
tell from that
very warm welcome,
we're so excited to
have all of you here.
Everyone has just
seen an amazing clip
from "The Best of Enemies."
And this was four years
ago, when we first
heard that you signed on,
Taraji, to be part of the film.
Can you tell us a little
bit about the process.
When you saw this,
what made you decide
that this was right for you?
TARAJI P. HENSON: Well,
Danny Strong, co-creator--
one of the co-creators
and producers of Empire
gave me this script when we
filmed the pilot for "Empire."
And then the show became a big
success, and it was hard for me
to schedule my schedule.
I had so many
scheduling conflicts.
And then, it was after
the 2016 election,
I noticed that the racial
climate change drastically.
So I called Danny,
and I was like,
we have to make this movie,
and we got to make it now.
And at the time, I
was already slated
to do "Proud Mary,"
on my hiatus.
And so he was like, you
already have a movie.
And I was like, I don't care.
Make it happen.
Make the dates work, and I
will give up my entire hiatus.
And that's what I did.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE:
That's fantastic.
And Robin, you had produced
some amazing blockbusters--
"Seabiscuit," "The
Hunger Games,"
"Pleasantville," but this
is your directorial debut.
ROBIN BISSELL: Yeah.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE: For you,
what made this your first?
How'd you choose?
ROBIN BISSELL:
Well, it was a story
I'd first heard about in 2005.
And so I had been really
anxious to do something with it.
At the time, as a
producer, you have
to find a writer and
a director and do
all that to have something
come to fruition.
But after "The
Hunger Games," I had
been thinking about wanting
to-- because I started out
as a singer-songwriter,
way back in the '90s,
and so I fancied
myself creative.
So after "The Hunger
Games," that was my time
I thought about directing.
And this is the
one thing I'd just
been wanting to do, just
tell the story regardless
of how I was involved.
And so I sat down, and I
called my friend, Danny Strong,
and said, I'm going
to start writing this.
And I did.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE: Great.
ROBIN BISSELL: Yeah.
Yeah.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE: And
what about you, Dominique?
Had you worked with
Robin or Taraji before?
How'd you decide to produce?
DOMINIQUE TELSON: No, I
hadn't worked with either one.
But actually, another
one of Robin's friends,
Matt Berenson--
I think they were tennis
partners is what he told me--
said, you know, my friend
Robin gave me this script.
So he read it, and
then he sent it to me.
And when I read it, I was like,
I want to make this movie.
I just fell in love with
the character of Ann Atwater
and, of course,
like everyone else,
googled, did she really exist,
is this really a real person,
and just was
fascinated by what she
was able to do in her community
with this film, and then
just in her life, as
a woman in this town.
And so I made it
my goal to make it.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE: Thank you.
Thanks for doing it.
Not just did she exist, but
I understand some of you
had a chance to meet her
before her passing in 2016?
ROBIN BISSELL: Yeah, so when I--
I'm sorry, did I interrupt you?
ROCHELLE BRISCOE: No.
ROBIN BISSELL: Did you
have another second half
to the question?
[CHUCKLING]
Yeah, so right after I
re-optioned the book--
because I had let the
option lapse in 2009.
I re-optioned the book in 2013,
and I beelined it for Durham.
And I called Ann, and
she was very open.
And she was in the
hospital at the time
because she hurt her knee.
And so we just started
having lunch and talking.
And I'd go back, and
then I kept going back.
And then Bill Riddick
also, who's still alive--
I just started spending
time with them.
And you know, Ann was just
sharp as a tack, literally,
up until she passed in 2016.
It's a big regret we didn't
get to get it done before
because she was so excited.
First, she was so excited that
Taraji was going to play her--
I mean, beyond.
[LAUGHTER]
And she was just so
excited for the movie--
yeah, really, a wonderful woman,
really wonderful-- and really
gave me a lot of perspective
as a filmmaker into not just
herself but what it was
like in the '50s, '60s,
and '70s in the south, and
great perspective on CP.
He wasn't alive anymore.
And seeing it through
her eyes allowed
me to three-dimensionalize
him more.
So--
DOMINIQUE TELSON: We
got a few of them.
I mean, the families came
on set and were there.
Bill Riddick was there
during the charette.
So he helped a lot.
Because you watch this, and
you go, how did this happen?
He goes, when I met
them, I couldn't
stand either one of them.
[LAUGHTER]
They were both nasty.
And so it was kind of great
to see that, that perspective,
because, again, it
three-dimensionalized the story
that Robin had written
in his screenplay.
And then, they
all came to this--
all his children
and grandchildren
and her children
came to the premiere
that we had.
We had a screening
in Durham for them.
And they were really,
really supportive
of the film, which was great.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE:
That's amazing.
Yeah, it definitely comes alive.
It's three dimensional.
You feel every bit of it.
And one of the areas
that really struck me
was just how extreme there
are-- some of the scenes.
And it's this very severe
optimism, matched shortly
with severe pessimism.
And for you, Taraji,
and you, Robin,
how do you embody
that in a character
and create that, as a director?
TARAJI P. HENSON: Uh, I
mean, well, I couldn't really
add too much because
Ann was a really--
a real person.
I just listened to
a lot of the stuff
people said about
her, that she was
a powerhouse, Roughneck Annie.
CP would always say you could
hear her before you see her.
[LAUGHTER]
She had a big mouth.
[CHUCKLES] So those are
real specific descriptions
of a person.
And that sounds
like somebody that
doesn't take no for an answer.
That sounds like somebody
that gets things done.
And the fact that she
went up against so many
powerful, white men,
and she was unafraid.
She was fearless.
She would die for the cause.
That's how important
it was for her
to leave this world
in a much better place
than she found it, for her
children and for a generation
after her.
And she wasn't rich.
She wasn't a rich woman.
She had no money, but she
had compassion in her heart.
And she was a true Christian
because, as Christians, you're
supposed to love your enemy.
It's hard to do, but she did it.
She just didn't back down.
I mean, good gracious,
I couldn't imagine.
[LAUGHTER]
When I had a
physicalize her, I just
imagined her when she gets--
she moved with a purpose.
You know, this is a woman
who, whenever she's moving,
she's moving with a purpose.
And I just imagine a locomotive.
You know what I mean?
And if you get in her way,
she's going to steamroll you.
[LAUGHTER]
So I just thought
about things like that.
And at the time, it
was so desperate.
It was like poor
people and black people
in particular, in
that community,
their backs were
against the wall.
What happens when you back
somebody up into a corner?
They come out swinging.
And I just kept that
on board every time,
that she wasn't just
fighting for herself
and for her children,
she was fighting
for the next generation.
And that's heavy
weight to carry.
ROBIN BISSELL: Yeah, and she was
just talking about their backs
are against the wall and
what your question was,
which was the juxtaposition
of pessimism and optimism.
And we live in such a
pessimistic time now.
We talk about how we first
heard the story years ago,
and it was relevant then.
And I think that in
these kind of times,
and then the
smallest bit of hope
really can save you,
even in an hour or a day.
People have the
smallest bit of hope.
It's like, oh, my god.
It might be OK.
And they embrace optimism, even
when it's a terrible landscape.
And these people were
the same way, I think.
And we talked about it.
Taraji and I and Dominique were
talking about it last night,
how these weren't just--
they were poor, and they
were in a small town--
Durham's a relatively
small town--
but they were leaders
within that town.
And so it's no accident that
there was a trickle down effect
from some people who
had a change of heart.
I mean, generational-- we've
been meeting with CP's family.
And his kids and grandkids,
there's no hate in them.
I mean, they're
wonderful people,
and that stopped because
of Ann stopped him.
And so you look at these people.
Bill Riddick was a leader.
Ann Atwater was a leader who
had people who would follow her
to the ends of the earth.
But she had her own ideology
as far as shutting herself off
to certain conversation.
CP-- obviously on
the wrong side,
but he had a lot of people
that would follow him.
So Bill Riddick was able
to work on Ann Atwater
to have her zoom out a little,
see a little bit of the bigger
picture because she had made
such a difference in people's
lives.
And this would allow
her to tap into CP,
who was another leader.
And she knew if she
could tap into him,
maybe that would trickle down.
Right?
And it's courage of leadership.
It's courage of moral courage.
And that's what
we're missing today.
I mean, there's
plenty of leaders
we know, plenty of our
people in Washington, who
know there's a gun problem, who
know there's a problem with law
enforcement, who know
there's a racial problem, who
know there's a climate problem.
They know.
They're not stupid, right?
But where's the courage?
Where's the courage
to lead the right way?
ROCHELLE BRISCOE: Yeah, we have
to dig into that ourselves,
as people.
I'm going to ask a
little more personally,
because I did spend 16
years in the Beltway,
so I'm going to stay away from
that for this conversation.
[LAUGHTER]
But in your own
personal experience,
is there something that
you drew from or thought
about when you're agreeing to be
in, produce, direct this story?
TARAJI P. HENSON:
I guess for me,
it was just what made
it so important for me
and why I gave up
my entire hiatus--
[LAUGHTER]
ROBIN BISSELL: She never
lets me forget that.
DOMINIQUE TELSON: Same.
TARAJI P. HENSON: --it's
because, I mean, you know.
You see this world.
And as an artist, I
feel like it is our duty
to reflect the times.
That's what we're
supposed to do as artists,
and I take that
responsibility very seriously.
Art has changed my life.
I have looked at
a visual painting,
and it has touched
me to the core
or shifted my
perspective or something.
Art is that powerful.
So whenever I pick
rolls, some might
be for fun, but a lot of them,
if you pay close attention,
it's examples of something to
leave for our kids or a message
to change a group of
people's perception
on another group of people.
The more stories that
we tell, the more
we are aware that different
stories and different people
exist.
And until we don't have to
make stories like this, where
we have to put a
mirror up to society
and say, hey, [NERVOUS CHUCKLE]
not looking so good--
clean it up-- then we will
continue to make these films.
They're important.
This is how you push
humanity forward.
So this is why did the film.
I felt it was like a great
responsibility of mine,
as an artist.
DOMINIQUE TELSON: Mm-hmm.
And I guess, as a producer,
when I read this script,
I have three
daughters, and they're
coming up in this world.
And it can be tough.
And when I saw this
example of Ann Atwater,
that's the message I
wanted them to know,
to have that hope that
look at this woman.
And she was fierce
and just kept going
and had the courage to do
what, really, no one else--
what no one else did.
And I want them to have the
hope that if you put yourself
into it, maybe there
is hope for change.
She was known as
Roughhouse Annie,
but in order to
reach CP, she had
to step back from
being Roughhouse Annie
and find a new way.
She had to find a way to his--
Taraji says this all the time--
but to his heart and soul.
And that's what she did.
And actually, that
takes a lot more courage
than it sometimes is
to just be roughhouse.
So I love this film
because of that.
I want them to see that.
And I want the world
to see this film.
And by the way, last
thing as a producer,
I love having diversity in
front of and behind the camera.
And we did that in Atlanta,
and we had a great crew.
And it was a real family on set.
And I think part of
the reason is because
of our diversity on set.
Even though we were dealing
with a rough subject matter,
we could look around
and say, you know what?
We can do this together.
ROBIN BISSELL: Yeah,
for me, it initially
was how I kept thinking
about how we put labels
on each other, and we define
each other in little catch
phrases without even
knowing each other.
I do it too.
I watch TV, or I get angry
just like everyone else.
And you put up these barriers
right away when you get angry.
And I learned to be a
better listener, I think,
through this process.
As artists, we don't
always get to make
films that are entertaining
and are relevant,
or and have this kind
of power or message.
Sometimes we do.
It's OK not to, but you know.
And so for people in this
two-dimensional world,
we're not really
listening to each other.
And we know that when you
make a movie, you get to put--
people are in a dark
room for two hours,
just listening and not talking.
You don't get that
opportunity very often, right?
And so if we can do it right and
have people engage and become
emotionally invested in the
real lives of these characters,
and then we can say
something that we want to say
and what they wanted
to say, that's
a huge platform to
be able to have.
And that's why it--
that's why I love
doing this, really.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE:
Yeah, that's the hope
that I felt, being
fortunate enough
to get a chance
to watch the movie
and recognize that maybe--
maybe it's possible to have
real, severe differences
and somehow get past that.
It seems like,
from your answers,
you all really believe
that it's still
possible for people to
be diametrically opposed
and on very different
sides of the line,
but to make a change today.
DOMINIQUE TELSON: Absolutely.
TARAJI P. HENSON: I
mean, God is very clever.
I'm not going to preach
to anybody today but--
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
I mean, if you believe
in a higher power, God,
I like to say, if
there was only supposed
to be one race to
all-mighty God,
there would only be one race.
God is very clever.
We all are here.
We look different.
We come from
different backgrounds,
paying attention for a reason.
And it's for us
to figure it out.
That's our job on life,
in life to figure it out,
to work it out.
And unfortunately, we have
this thing called social media,
and it has driven a
big divide between us
because you would think, yeah, I
could have a great conversation
on Twitter.
But it goes sour,
each and every time.
I just see a bunch of
people dragging each other.
No one's really listening
for understanding.
And it's a world of clickbait.
Real quick, soon as you hear one
thing, everybody jumps on it,
and they're believing.
And it's like wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Just from one phrase,
everybody believes this?
And it feels like it's
chaos, but it's up to us
to get it together
and figure it out
because we're here for a reason.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE: We are.
[CHUCKLING]
I'll say amen to you.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, I am
tasked today with--
I had a girlfriend
say, you guys are
going to talk about this
amazing film, civil rights,
and mental health.
How are you going to do this?
This is Taraji.
This woman does everything.
[LAUGHTER]
DOMINIQUE TELSON:
You have no idea.
ROBIN BISSELL: She does.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE: We're
going to make this work.
And I recognize
this period for you.
You've done things in this
space, our civil rights
era for African-Americans
with "Hidden Figures"
and now with "The
Best of Enemies."
And your father grew up
in the civil rights time.
Did he share his background
stories with you?
TARAJI P. HENSON: I
mean, it was rough.
One time he-- my
dad-- woo, I wish
he was alive to tell his story.
But, Vietnam vet coming
back with mental issues,
so he had a couple
run-ins with the law
that landed him in jail, in and
out of the mental institution.
Anytime you go to war, you
never come back the same.
But my father was an open book.
He didn't hide anything from me.
And he was very open and
honest about his mental state.
He was able to really work
through it and overcome it all.
But it was a huge adjustment
after coming back from Vietnam.
It took a while.
But again, you can't grow
if you sweep everything
under the carpet.
And that's my pain for the
African-American community.
We have generational trauma
that we don't deal with.
And we're walking around as if
everything is OK, and it's not.
We're walking around
of generations
of issues and trauma
swept under the carpet,
and we're standing on top of
it as if everything's fine.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE:
Yeah, you're right.
And it's generational.
It's impacted [? in the past. ?]
TARAJI P. HENSON: Some
things we don't even know
are affecting us because
it's so embedded in us.
We don't even know.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE: Yeah.
And outside of
your artist career,
last year, you opened
up a foundation
in your father's name.
TARAJI P. HENSON: Mm-hmm.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE: Can you
tell us about its mission?
TARAJI P. HENSON: The mission
is to work with the recidivism
in prison systems.
Because the prison system is
not really a place for reform
or to get your life
together [CHUCKLES]
and be implemented back out
into society a changed person.
It's really not.
It's to keep you there.
And it's unfortunate
because a lot of people
there have mental issues,
and they shouldn't even
be in cages.
And then we have to--
I was a substitute teacher
before I booked "Baby Boy"
and became an actress.
That was my gig
before I made it.
But I took it very
seriously, and I
chose to work with special
education children.
And in my mind, I thought
that meant disabled children
in wheelchairs that can't
eat or dress themselves.
And I get sent to
Crenshaw, and I get--
I'm in a classroom
with all black boys who
are labeled special ed but
nothing's wrong with them.
They can walk.
They can talk.
They smart out the mouth.
And I tell them, let's start
our work, and they do this.
I'm special ed.
I can't do that.
So just because they
have this label,
they already have a low
expectation of themselves.
And they believe it.
And it broke my heart.
So then that stood.
I carried that with
me for so many years
and all of this success.
And so when I came to launch
this foundation, I was like,
we need counselors-- not just
counselors but professional
therapists, psychiatrists,
that can go into these schools
and recognize that these
children are coming
from traumatic
experiences at home,
and we're expecting
them to learn.
Another thing that I've
been caring for years,
when I went to this same school,
the children are taking me
down the hall, and
they're like, Ms. Henson,
look, there was a
shootout here last night.
Ha ha ha!
And they're showing
me the bullets,
the bullets in the wall.
And I'm like-- And
they're walking around
like this is normal.
So you see what I mean?
We're expecting these
children to come home from god
knows these experiences
they're having at home, trauma.
And they're traumatized, trying
to come to school and learn.
And then when they
don't focus in class,
we slap a label on them
and say they're special ed,
but we don't try
to understand why.
And when I started talking
to these young boys,
one was found roaming around
by the train tracks, which
is in the backyard of the
school by the way, which
is another issue.
Trying to keep them
focused, and they've
got a train running through
the back yard every day.
It's whole lot of issues.
But anyway, he was roaming
around the train tracks.
He got picked up for
shoplifting at the 7-Eleven.
He was trying to
get something to eat
because his mother was on drugs
and his father was in prison.
How does that make
you special ed?
You can still learn.
You just have trauma at home.
So we need to implement
psychiatrists,
who are in these schools,
who can recognize the trauma
and give these children the
proper care that they need,
as opposed to just
labeling them special ed
and getting them ready
for the prison system.
So we're dealing with
that, and we're also
giving away scholarships to
young African-American children
because, see, we don't
talk about it at home.
It's taboo in our community.
So a lot of times,
our kids don't even
know that this is
a field to study,
that this is something I can
even go into because we're not
even talking about it at home.
So we need more
African-American--
and it's not even about a
color because I see therapists.
I need it.
And it's OK.
[CHUCKLES] I'll be the
first one to tell you
it's OK to not be OK.
But it's not even about a color.
It's cultural competency.
So I can understand
another culture's problems
if I take the time to.
But, see, a lot of times
you have these therapies
who are coming from
other countries,
and they just want the card
to come here and practice.
So again, you have these people
in these positions that really
don't even want to be there.
So it's a lot to cover, but
at least we're talking now.
At least we're talking.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE:
Yeah, thank you
for helping that conversation.
ROBIN BISSELL: Now,
you're wondering
why Ann Atwater--
or you're not--
why Ann Atwater wanted
Taraji to play her.
[LAUGHTER]
DOMINIQUE TELSON: Exactly.
TARAJI P. HENSON: She
called me the Cookie lady.
[LAUGHTER]
Cookie lady going to play me.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE: Yeah, this
is a modern civil rights issue.
In communities, now, the
difference in a time of crisis
from an appropriate training--
de-escalation.
We have this now, with officers,
to recognize the difference
in violence and mental health.
It's something that we
say civil rights era,
but we're still living
in this right now.
And mental health
isn't something
that's just stigmatized in the
African-American community.
Across countries,
communities, classes,
there are stigmas associated
with talking about it,
addressing it, sharing
that it's OK to be OK.
For you all, before
after this film,
have you ever had to
confront these stigmas
around mental health,
around needing to get help,
encouraging someone to get help?
And how do you all address it?
ROBIN BISSELL: My sister went
through a terrible divorce.
And she actually went through
something for a while.
It was the first
time in our family
that we had to deal with that.
And my parents are from the old
school, you know, east coast.
I grew up in suburbs,
kind of sheltered.
And they didn't really
want to talk about it.
And I was like,
what do you mean?
It's OK.
We can talk about it.
This wasn't that
long ago, you know?
And everything's fine, but
there was a stigma for us.
It was everything is OK.
Don't talk about it.
Well, that's no good because
then we're not asking for help.
It's OK to ask for help.
And I think that's where
any kind of stigma hurts.
It's that you
don't ask for help.
Right?
Asking for help is everything.
We see we've had, what?
A couple of high-profile
suicides lately, just
in the last couple of weeks.
It's been horrible.
And that's trauma.
And Taraji talking about trauma.
Our brains are so fragile.
Our emotions are fragile.
There's trauma we
don't even know about.
It's not just coming
home from war.
It's not-- do you
know what I mean?
And so I can't begin
to understand it,
but I do know that when
you get rid of stigma,
people will ask for help.
And as a father--
I have two boys.
One's here at Berkeley.
And I tell them all the
time, it's OK to ask me.
If anything's the matter,
don't be too strong--
or don't try to be.
TARAJI P. HENSON: It's--
I'm sorry.
I didn't--
DOMINIQUE TELSON: No, go ahead.
TARAJI P. HENSON:
It just is something
that gets under my skin.
And so many people
need this help,
but it just seems like
it's set up and designed
to make it as
difficult as possible
for you to get the help.
I'm talking even within
the SAG insurance.
That's something I'm
getting ready to tackle.
Like, why is it that I
can't use my insurance
to pay for my psychiatrist?
I'm an artist.
I need it!
[LAUGHTER]
DOMINIQUE TELSON: Yeah, wow.
[INAUDIBLE]
TARAJI P. HENSON: You know?
What is happening here?
[APPLAUSE]
My psychiatrist broke
that down to me.
She was like, you have this
amazing insurance program.
Blue Cross Blue
Shield does cover me.
But for whatever reasons, I'm
outside of network for SAG.
Go figure.
What are we doing here?
ROCHELLE BRISCOE: Mm.
We are fortunate and blessed
to have you, all of you,
tackling these issues on the
screen, off of the screen.
Thank you for being here.
We could talk about this
for a while, obviously.
But for our audience,
for all of the audiences
out there, if I
could ask each of you
as a final question,
what do you want people
to take away from this film?
DOMINIQUE TELSON: I want
people to see the film
and be inspired--
be inspired to look
at your neighbor.
I think we were talking,
before, about Twitter wars
and whatever.
But if you really have to look
the other person in the eye
and really have a
conversation, maybe there's
something we can do with that.
And that's what I hope people
are inspired by, by Ann
and what she was able to do,
and by the transformation
that CP made, and have hope that
maybe we can come out of this,
and the next generation
is left a little
better off than
ours is right now.
I mean, honestly, I'm looking
out at your audience here,
and it's wonderful to see.
When I started
working corporate,
it did not look like this.
[LAUGHTER]
ROCHELLE BRISCOE:
No, we're YouTube.
When you said you feel proud
on the stage to have the back,
you know, behind the scenes--
this is us.
This is behind the
scenes, and we're proud.
A lot of people put in a
lot of work [INAUDIBLE]
DOMINIQUE TELSON:
Congratulations.
I've worked corporate jobs.
This doesn't look like this.
And it's just so--
so I hope that this
is possible because of that.
Just a quick-- she
doesn't even know this,
but when I came to the country,
I didn't speak English,
so I got put in special ed.
And then it's like, I just
didn't speak the language.
And then I had to get test--
there's nothing wrong with me.
Just teach me English.
[LAUGHTER]
It's crazy.
TARAJI P. HENSON:
They were getting
you ready for the prison.
DOMINIQUE TELSON: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Exactly.
ROBIN BISSELL: Instead,
she's in the movie business.
I don't know.
DOMINIQUE TELSON: Woo.
Shew.
ROBIN BISSELL: For me,
it's the same thing.
There's so many things
to talk about this story.
Right?
We can talk about it
all day, like you said.
But really what worked
here was [INAUDIBLE]..
Right?
And so, what
Dominique was saying,
when you sit in
front of someone,
even if you start
arguing, you're
not going to argue forever.
You really let down
your defenses when
you're-- you're not as
aggressive when you--
you see people in
road rage videos,
which I've watched
a lot on YouTube
because it's really fun.
[LAUGHTER]
But I've gone through
these, believe me.
So you see what people
say to each other
when they're behind that--
DOMINIQUE TELSON: Wall.
ROBIN BISSELL: --the glass.
You know what I mean?
But you stand up, and you
walk to someone-- you're not
going to say those things.
Some people, I guess.
And so you sit down, and
you start talking to people,
and, oh, you have children.
And, oh, you like this.
And, oh, you went
to school here.
And, oh, you grew up here.
You start forgetting
your differences.
And you might still
have them, but you
can talk about it respectfully.
You can find common ground.
It's not brain surgery.
It might be brain surgery
to get us all together.
But once you're there,
you let down your veneer,
and you just start seeing
each other as human beings.
It's just what happens.
ROCHELLE BRISCOE:
Well, I was encouraged.
The movie's coming
out on April 5.
I think we will
all be encouraged.
Thank you.
Thank you for the movie.
Thank you for your foundation.
Thank you for this time today.
DOMINIQUE TELSON: Thank
you for having us.
ROBIN BISSELL: Thank you.
TARAJI P. HENSON:
Thank you so much.
ROBIN BISSELL: Thank
you, guys, for having us.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]